employment and business and financial
careers are expected to grow seven
percent through 2031. skilled MBA
graduates with global business
perspectives and hands-on experience who
can collaborate solve problems and make
data-driven decisions for their
businesses and organizations we'll have
countless opportunities
hi my name is Brian kench and I'm dean
of the Pompeii College of Business at
the University of New Haven
Welcome to our online MBA program that
we offer in collaboration with simply
learn
the University of New Haven founded on
the Yale campus in 1920 is a private
co-educational university that has been
recognized for academic Excellence by
the Princeton Review and the U.S news
and World Report as a University of New
Haven MBA student you will build your
knowledge base and sharpen your skills
to become a strategic collaborative and
corporate thinker who is ready to
navigate the business challenges
professionals face today
here are some key features of this
program
earn an MBA degree in alumni membership
from an aacsb accredited University
pursue stem designated concentrations
that enable you to earn sought after
skills leading to a higher salary and
better job opportunities
take part in an optional campus
immersion at the University of New Haven
in Connecticut USA experience a learning
path designed to help you earn
leadership roles at top companies
our MBA caters to professionals from a
wide variety of Industries
University of New Haven faculty deliver
Innovative and cutting-edge courses and
Core Business subjects
and then students will take a series of
advanced courses and electives in a
concentration area of your choosing
we offer our renowned MBA program
specially curated for an affordable fee
and delivered in collaboration with
simply learn providing a great
opportunity for Indian students 24 7
support is offered through email chat
and calls with the dedicated team what's
more continued access to community Forum
even after completing your MBA you can
experience all aspects of the program
from your own home or office and the
cost is a fraction of an equivalent on
campus program
program so unique
pay College of Business is aacsb
accredited a prestigious distinction
placing us among the top five percent of
business programs across the globe
ultimately though the true measure of
greatness is our alumni who have gone on
to Executive roles with such
organizations as KPMG NCR Nestle PWC
Pfizer Dupont MasterCard worldwide and
many other Fortune 500 companies as well
as successful startups and
entrepreneurial Ventures are you ready
to be our next success story get in
touch with one of our program advisors
who will walk you through the
application process
foreign
[Music]